So I understand how I can have different phenotypes, but
I can't really keep straight which alleles cause which phenotypes.
>> That's a really good point, and there's actually a really good solution for
it, too. We can actually symbolize which
allele causes which phenotype. For example, we
can symbolize lactase persistence with the plus
sign or the positive sign here, and
lactase non-persistence with the minus sign or
the negative sign. This means that the T
allele would be associated with the plus
symbol, and the C allele would be associated
with the minus symbol. So, if we rewrite
all of our allelic combinations that are possible
we'll remember that there are three possibilities. T/T,
T/C or C/C. And now that means we
can have plus, plus. Plus minus and minus,
minus. This gives us a far more functional
looking symbol that tells us maybe a little bit about the phenotype. Rather than
just the letter itself, which can be
hard to remember which phenotype it's associated with.
>> Okay, so that's a lot easier to follow now.
>> Well, notice that in the case of lactose
intolerance, all you need is one allele of lactase
persistence, so that you can actually digest lactose in
the first place. Okay, but how is that possible?
>> Well, Remember, because all you need is some
lactase protein around the digest lactose at all. Having one allele,
the T allele, will give you enough lactase protein at all
to be able to digest lactose. Let's think about it like
we did in our recipe analogy from lessons 3 and 4.
>> Okay, okay. I'm with you.
>> Alright. What we're going to do this time, is, instead of
using lots of different ingredients, we're going to use an ingredient, cheese.
Now, I see. So, we have one gene, but two types
of alleles. We have the cheddar allele and the mozzarella allele.
>> Exactly, and just like in a gene, we have two copies of
the alleles for that gene. So, Lauren,
what are the possible allelic combinations here?
>> Well, we can have two cheddars.
>> Right. Which would be our two T alleles.
>> Or we can have. Two mozzarellas.
>> Right, which would represent our two C alleles.
>> Or, we can have one mozzarella and one cheddar.
>> Right, this would be the heterozygous condition where we have both a T
allele and a C allele. So, really the important question now,
is in this heterozygous condition, which flavor are we going to
taste? Well, I think you taste the cheddar flavor, because that's
going to overpower the mozzarella flavor, because it's just a stronger flavor.
>> Exactly. This allele is going to be dominant, and so this
flavor's actually going to overpower the flavor of the mozzarella, which means.
>> That you're going to need two mozzarellas to be
able to taste the flavor of the mozzarella, right?
>> Exactly.
Now think about all the genotypes and phenotypes surrounding the trait
of lactase persistence. I want you to match each genotype to the
expected phenotype here. So for each genotype that you see, select
whether or not you think it'll be lactose tolerant or lactose intolerant.